thank you
Hollywood's biggest night and the crown
jewel of award season is almost here
look what we did here see we're doing a
little movie setting scene for you it is
time we even got pop we got popcorn it's
actually edible it's time for the Oscars
but while the movie industry
congratulates itself it is dealing with
some huge challenges Luciano discovered
how one family's livelihood was upended
by Hollywood's uncertain future
let's all go to the lobby George
Mitchell's memories are so vivid you can
almost smell the popcorn from the day
Motion Pictures arrived to his small
Seaside town of Niantic Connecticut I
came here for opening night they were
playing uh All the King's Men
and you came for that first show that
first yes I did the first day the first
day
he says that for 30 years looking up at
that big screen was like going to church
his family eventually owned and managed
the theater but their story ended last
year when the pandemic came our business
dropped to zero it was the end it was a
death blow for us though kovid may have
put the final nail in the coffin for
theaters like Mitchell's streaming was
already forcing a shift what has been
the impact of streaming on this business
well it's tremendous tremendous I mean
when you you see them walking out of
Best Buy and some of these other places
with the 70-inch screens and all you
know you've lost customers ticket sales
are down about
percent from pre-pandemic levels
something entertainment journalist Matt
bellany says is unsustainable for
smaller Cinemas for a while we thought
kovid was going to kill theaters in
general what's the pulse of movie
theaters like at this point the result
after covet is that we're seeing the box
office concentrated in fewer movies
bigger grosses for the movies like
Spider-Man no way home
top gun Maverick Avatar weight of water
but it's that middle and lower tier that
is really struggling all 10 of the top
10 movies at the box office in 2022 were
sequels or prequels and that is very
disturbing to a lot of moviegoers who
want these kinds of more adult more
serious movies to do well in theaters so
Studios have an incentive to put in
there with what vitamins peptide tea DDC
anything but that poison you're Hawking
movies like The Indie hit Dallas Buyers
Club which earned Matthew McConaughey
the best actor Oscar and producer Rachel
winter a best picture nomination in 2014
has what gets made changed Once Upon a
Time you know you had a big giant movie
star and you were just guaranteed to
have this wonderful hit and things have
changed the good news is that with
access to content and access to make
content there are lots of more
opportunities to tell different kinds of
stories
well streaming companies have made all
sorts of films more readily available to
larger audiences winter still laments
the downsizing of Cinema look I like
being on my couch and in my pajamas and
enjoying a movie I enjoy that as much as
the next person but I will never stop
wanting to go to the movies
and for that to go on bellany says the
answer is clear what can the audience do
if we want to see more grown-up movies
the biggest thing you can do if you like
seeing these movies released in theaters
is go see them in theaters
well and I have some news in Niantic the
loss of the downtown movie theater is
not a total loss for the Arts since we
visited the Art House has found it's new
life or happy ending in an even older
art form as the Niantic Bay Playhouse
home of the local theater troupe call it
movie Magic so it still can until it
still continues I was struck by what
George said when you see these people
coming out of Best Buy with these big
TVs because I remember getting a big TV
being very excited so I could watch
movies at home I didn't think about the
other side where you said there goes
another customer the home theater that
was the idea of the home theater well
now it's kind of material but I do
lament the loss of the theater going
experience which I love I lament the
loss of wonderful sort of independent
films although we've had some I'm happy
to see everything everywhere all at once
doing so well because you look at that
list that Matt bellany pointed to of all
these sequels and look I'm the biggest
comic book movie nerd yeah I will go see
those films but I love the great films
the pulp fictions of the day and a film
like everything everywhere all at once
and I hope that people will continue to
support them but I like what Matt said
in your piece if you want these movies
to survive please go and see them I
still love going to the theater too me
too last movie you guys saw in the movie
theater everything everywhere all at
once whole family we gotta know we gotta
know eating girl so my kids love going
to the theater because then they can
just eat all the junk and fall
everywhere
what a great piece Lilia thank you